foreign
so Ken it is the time of year when
people reset their lives you've got a
white board that's erased you can write
anything on this new year that you want
there's something grace-filled about a
new year and sometimes people kind of do
ish or wish they call it a resolution
and then they change nothing that's
right because the resolution is just
that it's something that I kind of feel
like I want to do maybe there's some
guilt driving the resolution maybe
there's a wish there might have been
some champagne involved that's resetting
the resolution that's a good point maybe
even peer pressure and all of them goal
setting that's a resolution so we set a
resolution but as you know the data is
just abysmal they all fall off around
February yeah Jim Gibbs gets empty again
is is Hell years ago there were no
machines available in January I was
working with a personal trainer and he
said no problem just wait till
Valentine's Day there won't be a soul in
here 45 days in the gym is empty yeah so
that's the difference in a resolution an
ish a wish a goal a goal is something
you actually do goals are dreams with
work boots on and it means asking what
do I need to do differently
what has to be true
that was not true before
to get this Abundant Life
and that's why you're listening to us
you want a more Abundant Life we want
that for you we love you we bust you we
encourage you we pray for you we cry
with you we do everything on this show
also you can have an Abundant Life a
more Abundant Life and taking the steps
to do intentionality with that so let's
do an old-fashioned goals setting lesson
Ken the old guys I mean Brian Tracy Zig
Ziglar used to say there's a wheel of
life and you need to set goals and be
achieving and growing in all of these
areas you need financial goals you need
intellectual goals you need family goals
spiritual goals physical goals career
goals and social goals and all of those
are important and generally speaking
each of us have one of those categories
or two that we're really naturally good
at comes easy for us yes and uh one or
two that are really difficult for us
that's right and so you said something
earlier I want to just hone back on you
said goals are dreams with work boots on
that implies some intentionality and
diligence to actually say okay this is
what specifically I want to accomplish
and then I've got to actually get up and
do that uh and so I want to know your
thoughts because I know you've been
teaching this for a very long time
certainly with Entre leadership our
business division here at Ramsey
solution so how do we put work boots on
goals when you set a goal then you have
to start figuring out and writing down
how you're going to accomplish it okay I
want to lose 30 pounds right win okay
over 90 days that's 10 pounds a month
200 pounds a week now what are you going
to do to do that just just set in the
gold and do anything that's right but
I'm gonna drink more water I'm going to
exercise I'm going to cut out Breads and
sweets okay now we've got some tactical
things we're doing to actually cause the
weight to lose I want to I want to uh
get out of debt okay I gotta get extra
job I got to cut out the subscriptions I
got to sell the stupid motorcycle sit in
the garage whatever it is right and so
you're going to take some actions to hit
the goals and unless you do the needle's
not going to move now go goals that work
are just dreams
unless there are five things they need
to a be number one be specific number
two they need to be measurable number
three they need to have a time limit so
I want to lose weight is measurable but
it's not specific
yeah I want to lose 30 pounds is
measurable and specific but then you ask
the question how long do you want you
want to lose up 30 pounds over the next
10 years or how many times do you want
to lose 30 pounds yeah that's okay so I
want to lose 30 pounds over three months
now we've got it like I said a while ago
90 days that's 10 pounds a month two and
a half pounds a week as soon as you put
a time limit on the goal you can back
the math out okay I want to read through
the Bible great when in a year okay 12
months well now we can look at the
number of chapters in The Bible the
number of books in the Bible they have
an Old Testament New Testament read
through the bible plan there's lots of
them I want to run a marathon great win
and now we can back into a training plan
of how many miles I got to run to get
ready for that uh the LA the next two
things is goals need to be in writing
why is it important that they're in
writing
I'm not positive but I have achieved
almost none of my goals in my life if I
didn't write it down yeah the Bible says
in habakkuk habakkuk tutu write the
vision and make it plain
I I it's almost weird magical but it's
uh you're pretty much ensure it's not
going to happen but something about when
it leaves your mind and you and you
write it and I I would physically write
it like you like to write with a pencil
I do I do absolutely do and I think
there's something that happens there the
in the the physiology of that that
causes us to go okay I'm going to lose
30 pounds and you ride it out I'm gonna
I'm gonna make a hundred thousand
dollars this year and you write it out
that's eighty three hundred thirty three
dollars a month that's 2100 a week what
have I got to do to get there you know
and you once you start
putting it on paper it's there and the
last one of the goals it has to be your
goals not your mama's not your wife
that's important my wife wants me to
lose 30 pounds not gonna work my mama
wanted me to be a dentist I don't want
to be your patient okay uh you know
don't live other people's goals live
your goals and you people in leadership
help people set goals that they set when
you set goals for them it's not a goal
it's a quota it's so true and what will
happen is a goal towards a desired
future that's not your desired future is
you just laid out some examples those
goals now become distractions they're
actually distractions from what you
should be doing you'll never finish them
our team's built a guide for you to help
you do goal setting go to
ramsesolutions.com
goals and it'll help you with this
because again you need to touch these
different areas you need to do the seven
different things Financial intellectual
family spiritual physical career and
social and in each of those areas then
you need goals that are specific they
need to be measurable they need to have
a time limit they need to be in writing
and you have to have personal emotional
ownership of them they have to be your
goals and you can put we can put forth a
thousand examples of people that have
done this and how it works and oh by the
way
if you didn't lose 30 pounds but you
lost 28. yeah I think you won yeah
absolutely you know there's an old
phrase out there we don't know who it's
attributed to but the person who aims
for nothing hits it every time and I'll
tell you I've used this this tool this
tool is unbelievable because it guides
you through it so you don't have to
stress out we're going to give you the
categories the financial intellectual
family spiritual physical career social
and we walk you through how to actually
use this and it's going to keep you
accountable oh this is a wonderful guide
to really make some serious gains in all
of these areas in your life in 2023.
well I'll help you with the financial
side because it's free there's that too
yeah that's true all right
ramseysolutions.com goals ish is a wish
drunken resolutions don't count we're
setting real goals this is grown-ups
we're setting goals